I'm blue if I was green I wouldn't die
I'm in need of a guy I could beat up a
guy
I could beat up a guy I could beat on
the guy I knew she loved a guy I could
beat up a guy I can beat our God I think
you're ready for fish jelly
I don't think you're ready for this
jelly I don't think you're ready for it
salsa I'm a ball boy Suffolk's sssss on
the ball boy weed brownies on the ball
boy sososo says it's also on the ball
boy we round him I let my brains down in
Africa I let my brains down in Africa
yeah baby can you breathe
a cactus from Jamaica it always works
for me hey it's called a tooth decay no
more pretending hey cuz now you'll win a
hey hey hey hey hey hey there is a
cactus right here dude hit me with your
best shot hit me with your pet shark
Oh hit me with your pet shark okay okay
okay okay
your bet you think that's really funny
huh so fancy can't you taste this gold
remember my name bout to blow piss on
the point you pass me the door on a
spring this week and we're talking at
the point which impacts the Patrick
tragedy passion back wallaby eg out what
was that the greatest rapper alive but
um oh wow bullets went out to the bow
sponsored by Nike throw up on Mexicans
throw up on Mexicans throw up on
Mexicans
one Mexicans PJ server while his gonna
show me a fight for now and I tell you
baby it was easy
coming back continue once I figured it
now
you were right here he's got a chicken
to ride she's got a chicken rawhide
where's the chicken I was just here
Keats got a chicken to ride but he don't
in this video let me do the what is that
we're going to try you like one of my
french girls one crush